[Musique]
Jean-Luc madc bonjour on se retrouve
pour un nouveau numéro de de bouche à
oreille et là vous allez nous parler de
quoi je vais vous parler du beurre du
beurre la cuisine au beurre la cuisine
au beurre la fameuse cuisine au beurre
c'est d'ailleurs une très jolie histoire
finalement qui mêle à la fois la
religion et la gastronomie ah bon et oui
parce que c'est en Europe du Nord dans
le Haut Moyen-Âge he qu'on retrouve les
recettes au beurre le beurre éant tisu
du lait bien entendu c'est la matière
grasse du lait et très bizarrement le
beurre ne viendra dans les royaumes de
France que plus tard et grâce à un
échange finalement involontaire entre
des pays puisque c'est dans ces pays
scandinaves hein ce qui est aujourd'hui
la Suède la Norvège le danemar l'land
absolument au beur c'est un peu plat
mais en même temps on ne mange pas de
beurre dans le royaume de France sauf à
partir du moment où l'Église au 17e
siècle autorise à ce qu'on fasse la
cuisine au beurre les jours maigres
tiens et oui et à partir de là estce
qu'on faisait quoi
avantuile huile d'olive huile de noix au
lar et au sein dou oui s évid voilà le
beurre n'était pas utilisé quasiment pas
et petit à petit alors que les pays du
sont des pays protestants à l'époque le
beurre grâce à cette autorisation donnée
par l'Église commence à investir les
recette au nord de la Loire et petit à
petit descendent au sud de la Loire et
c'est à partir de là que le beurre va
triompher de l'huile du saintdou et du
lard pour intégrer d'abord les recettes
des sauces jusqu'à ce qu'au 18e siècle
il est totalement à la mode et là on
fait la cuisine c'est c la cuisine au
beurre
elle parce que moi j'avais quand même
l'impression que moi j'étais dans le sud
quand j'étais petit il y avait quand
même une frontière il y avait la cuisine
à l'huile quand même dans le sud et puis
les Normands le Nord tout ça c'était la
cuisine au beurre euh alors oui c'est
vrai Patrice pour être très franc le
beurre n'a pas investi facilement la
Provence par exemple hein le l'huile
d'olive est resté et toujours
aujourd'hui maîtresse dans les recettes
mais cependant pendant une période
importante 19e début 20e siècle le beur
a tout dominé et donc il était alors
notamment dans les restaurants et dans
les auberges euh impensable de ne pas
avoir des recettes où les sauces ne
soient pas faites au beurre voilà alors
petit à petit la diététique a repris le
pouvoir les grands spécialistes et les
producteurs se sont adaptés euh alors je
ne ferai pas l'apologie des beurs
allégers cependant c'est vrai que les
grands professionnels dans ce domaine
qui ont des marques extraordinaires
reste très présente sur les tables
restent très présent dans les recettes
et c'est vrai que aujourd'hui les
méthodes de fabrication du beur
permettent d'avoir une cuisine quand
même un petit peu àég un peu moinse
merci
[Musique]
beaucoup